on the issues relating to the fight
against money laundering mutual
recognition of freezing and confiscation
orders to fight against terrorism and
the position which Europe needs to take
on terrorists fighter returnees we've
had a very healthy discussion I
encouraged Member States to make better
use of euro just I also invited
ministers to continue sharing experience
on preventing radicalization in prisons
to prevent terrorism we also intend to
root out terrorist financing through
confiscation of criminal assets I
updated ministers on the Commission's
work on access to electronic evidence
our goal a must be straight forward
arrangements for cross-border access to
electronic evidence accompanied by
strong procedural rights safeguards if a
person I don't know buys an app or a
software which has digital content we
wanted to create a situation where the
rights of the consumer are protected
much and much more we had a discussion
on whistleblowers I think that it was a
very open debate on how we can improve
whistleblowing protection both on our
member states but also on whether this
idea should be implemented on a European
level today it was another step forward
towards a possible establishment of the
European public prosecutor's office